reg how are you this morning Theodore I
am fantastic how are you and my lovely
danette we're doing well morale is high
I can't say the same about Oklahoma City
now I saw there was a column that said
stop saying Oklahoma City choked did
Oklahoma City choke it's easy to come up
that narrative obviously being up 31 and
you had the team with the most wins ever
during the regular season 73 gold
estates on the rope but I'm going to
lean towards the other way that Golden
State found a way to take the series
away and I don't know if it I was on
your show or another show talking about
if there ever was a team that had the
firepower to come back from a 3-1
deficit and it was set up where all they
had to really do was win one game in okc
because they had the advantage of having
game five in game 7 at home so when they
won game five which was a tough to me
the weight the Thunder played in Game
five on the road really pushing the
Warriors in that game really set up the
matchup for game six and they had him on
the ropes and down the stretch it was
the resiliency of the world champ
binding away there's no way they're in
that position though for game 7 if it
was not for klay Thompson klay Thompson
was the difference in Game six because
the excuse me the Warriors had their
head in the sand it was there for the
taking but Golden State found a way so
I'm going to lean towards more that it
was the Warriors who went out and took
it as opposed to a thunder choking is
this a rivalry Golden State in cleveland
or are we just trying to make it a
rivalry i would say it's its burgeoning
a robbery because of obviously what
happened last year LeBron James was
fantastic but he didn't have two of his
running mate now that love and
Kyrie both healthy subtle trash talk
going back and forth you know between
LeBron and stuff yes he did when the MVP
he was deserving of the MVP but it's
feel most valuable you know those are
little jab you know to kind of poke the
bear on both guys but if if you set
everyone down and ask what two teams
would you love to see in the finals
you'd probably get a consensus that you
want to see a rematch of last year with
everyone healthy but LeBron it's sort of
like he said look it's not but you know
Steph and me and stuff it said the same
thing but you know it used to be it was
bird against magic or it was Michael
against the bowls they did it's like
they don't really want to say that this
is about these two but it is it's about
it's about legacies here LeBron going to
six consecutive finals to win a title
and going through Steph Curry the team
that beat him last year or steph going
back to back and back-to-back MVPs I
mean this is a rivalry between these two
because I think they both consider
themselves still the best player in the
game absolutely and look these two guys
have have been and will be the face of
the league for the next you know eight
to ten years LeBron James has done it so
long and now steph has kind of taken
that mantle as you just mentioned
back-to-back MVPs coming off a world
championship and a chance for the
Warriors you know for immortality you
know it to win a championship obviously
is great but when you win back-to-back
that's when you're mentioned as you said
with the bulls with the Lakers with the
Celtics so there's a lot riding on here
for Golden State and to me the bigger
story would be winning a championship
for Cleveland you know a team that's had
a Sportster out for what is it for 50
years now going on so you know that's a
huge story in itself so it comes down to
its to uh you know leading men here and
steph curry and LeBron James so you know
they can deflect all they want but when
you are the free the face of a
corporation like these to have
and are going to be in stephs case you
know for the next eight to ten years
you've got to embrace the moment Golden
State winning a championship following
63 regular season wins does that make
them the best team of all time look it's
going to be hard for me to go against
that Chicago Bulls Michael Jordan team
but if you're not a sports fan and you
are a casual viewer to our game and you
look at the Warriors on paper you have
to say that but for people like yourself
myself who's played the game you know
who knows the ins and outs in the
particulars you're probably going to
side with that Chicago Bulls team but on
the surface what this team has done
let's think about this now they've
dodged two huge bullets to get to this
point Steph's ankle and then me in the
first and second round with him missing
times being pushed to the brink but a
thunder being down 3-1 and finding a way
to win that Series in seven and now
you've arguably got the best team
playing in the postseason if you were to
reseed was the Cleveland Cavaliers so
they find a way to win a championship I
mean that is three huge obstacles that
was in the golden state warriors way and
to win back-to-back championships with
all that and on top the cherry on top
you had your coach for half the year
it's been real a remarkable run for
Golden State but having said all that
you still got LeBron James wait is this
is it's going to be a great series he's
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer joining
a Stan Patrick show who is more
embraceable likeable staffer LeBron
well everyone talks about we us loving
change change is good you know and the
new hot commodity on the market
obviously is deaf because we haven't
seen what you know he has done no one
has seen that with the 3s the dribbling
extradition and you know the 40 footers
you know the the choir boy looks and a
smile it's nice and all but LeBron James
has we talked about being the face of
the league the last 10 years and to go
to you know people love to hate on
LeBron to go to six straight NBA Finals
people you need to understand there are
so many things that could go wrong along
the way to go to six between an ankle
sprain you know someone else getting
injured on your team other teams getting
better there's so many things that can
go wrong in route 26 straight NBA Finals
you know people like say well he's only
two and four in those finals give me two
and four in six I'd rather be two and
four in in NBA Finals then you know we
were talking about this with the boys is
it better to be two and four in NBA
Finals or 0 in for in Super Bowls like
the Buffalo Bills ever owned four hour
and 30 and 40 and 44 consecutive okay
how about this would you rather be 2 and
4 or 2 and 0 I would rather be 2 and 4 6
times on the biggest stage because once
you get to the NBA Finals it's it really
is anyone's game it could be look easy
could be one in five if it's not for Ray
Allen think about that I don't know
think about that right yeah that's how
close yeah that's how that's the margin
of error it really is but this is going
to come down to LeBron either winning or
losing Steph either winning or losing
but more more to LeBron winning or
losing then you know Steph might not get
as much criticism if they don't win as
much as LeBron might
they don't win whether or not if Dirk
and Jason Terry and Rick Carlisle you
know revising their game plan in the
middle of that series LeBron could be
three and three right so I mean it it's
it's all about stuff you know I hate to
say you know it's a team game obviously
yes but if steph doesn't play at its
highest if he doesn't play like he
played you know in game 7 and if lebron
lebron went great all postseason but
those two guys have to play at the
highest level we know what we're going
to get from clay clay has been
spectacular during this postseason
draymond is going to have to be better
but it's funny because in last year's
finals you know David Blatt in my
opinion was a little bit hard-headed of
not changing his lineup and staying with
Mozgov well that's not the case this
year because they start Tristan Thompson
so it's going to be interesting if and
watch tonight and as this serie goes on
how many pick-and-rolls that Steve Kerr
puts Kevin Love in defensively either as
the primary defender on Steph Curry or
being the rotation over the late
defender coming over when the screen and
roll happens Kevin Love is going to get
a full dose at defense because they're
going to try to take out one of their
big three and I would not be surprised
if it's Kevin Love they are going to
attack Kevin Love left and right to try
to take one of the big three of
Cleveland's away so watch as this series
goes on how many pick-and-rolls to move
his feet to move Kevin love's feet that
he is in but they also want to have him
switched so you have him out there on
courier klay Thompson and then you
create that mismatch well good luck good
luck with that okay the claimed she saw
how that ended up with with the Thunder
with the switching the klay Thompson
game in Game six you've been around the
game for a long long time have you ever
seen anybody lock in like that now I
know he makes 11 threes but I'm just
talking about locking in in a shooting
performance where you just go it did
that Moses saying I I probably can
compare that
to da Nova was Game one or game to
Michael Jordan versus Portland when he
you know it kind of gives magic to shrug
when he's knocking down all the threes
and he was just locked in in terms of
offensive gamesmanship and just being in
the zone I probably put those two
scoring exhibitions in the same but I
had never seen I mean like I love
shooting you know that it wasn't even in
his hand before he was locked and loaded
and released that was just that was that
was breathtaking indesit we need to
start people Oh seriously talking about
Steph and klay arguably the best
backcourt ever and I know people are
going to go crazy now on Twitter but
we've got to start mentioning them
especially if they go back to back here
we can throw out names like Joe and
Isaiah Gayle and Jerry what Walt Frazier
and marina Earl the Pearl Jordan in
whoever Uzi and Sherman were they
together Bob koozie and sure no I don't
know who koozie had a disjoint I think
there were just a point guard he was the
point guard then everybody else was four
but think about us I'll be who else are
we going to really throw in there bro I
had Sam Jones as he's back there Jones
right Finn okay oh who else we have
magic magic and iron magic and Barnes
gun yeah it when you're gonna talk mahal
favorites when you talk about best ever
okay both players have to probably be in
the Hall of Fame right if i gave you
clay and staff or jordan and bj
armstrong you not not there but i would
go I would go with Stephanie all right
okay okay but all with Steph and klay
but it might be a little closer than
what baby a little okay if i gave you do
mars in Isaiah okay now we're talking
stepping out walking I i would go with
joe and Zeke just for the simple
fact you know people forget Joe can lock
you down and I I would assume that Joe
would be on staff and Isaiah would
probably be chasing clay around but that
would be I would go with Joe and Joe and
Zeke I'd love to have seen Isaiah play
Steph Curry those two and that wouldn't
have been fan tonight mean it's great
for us to talk about their water-cooler
it's great but you know I even get kind
of cuz I don't like to compare you know
the all-time greats with you know
current players because it's not fair
this step is not fair to LeBron is not
fair to clay but it's just good you know
you and I to sit down the danettes and
to banter because we would love to see
that what rules will be play with you
know it's it's good to talk about but
it's not fair to the current players
because right now there they are
rewriting and writing their own legacy
right now but that would be a fun
matchup I still would have to go with
Joe and Zeke great stuff as always reg
thanks for joining us and enjoy the
hoops Theodore you the best well hold on
before me off who you have and I got
clearly i got Cleveland and I don't it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
Cleveland huh yeah I will say this it is
set up for Cleveland to win if they
everything is in their favor because
you've got a tired Golden State team in
Game one except for the court advantage
a right but having said all that like I
said they've already dodged two bullets
with with the steph injury and then
being on the brink down 3-1 something
one in 73 games something special again
is brewing I gotta go with the Warriors
in seven I really do but I would not be
if the if the Cavs lose then there
really is a curse seriously there really
is a curse if the Cavs lose everything
is set up for them to win Thank You reg
you're the best thanks buddy love y'all
that's Reggie Miller old Famer the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you